How's it going everyone? This is going
to be a video over SMT within the
fractal model. Now it is important to
note that SMT is not used to force
yourself upon a model, but it is used as
a confluence within the model. So I'm
not going to randomly use SMT and then
try to find a model within that, but I'm
going to first find a model and then see
if it has SMT for extra confluence.
Let's get into the PDF. So what is SMT?
SMT is a divergence between correlated
markets. So for instance, if I have the
S&P 500 here or ES and Nasdaq here,
those are correlated markets. They
should be moving in the same direction.
However, if they have a difference in
structure, so for instance here, the S&P
makes a higher high while the Nasdaq
makes a lower low,
that would be a divergence between
correlated markets, also known as an
SMT, and that is what we can use to give
confluence to a reversal. So that is
what an SMT is. How do we use it within
the fractal model? Within the fractal
model, and this is what it looks like on
the lower time frame, I'm going to be
looking for a model, so a candle two or
a candle three closure paired with a
change in the state of delivery on a
lower time frame, and then referencing
that correlated market to see if it has
an SMT. So here you can see we have a
candle two closure. We have a lower time
frame change in the state of delivery.
Only once I have a model that has
formed, do I look at the correlated
market. Here you can see I can look at
the correlated market and it has formed
a lower high while we have formed a
higher high. So I can go ahead and mark
out that SMT on the lower time frame or
as well on the higher time frame, and
that can give me a confluence to this
reversal forming. And that will be an
SMT between candle one and candle two.
Now we can also have an SMT between
candle two and candle three, which is a
continuation SMT. So this is a reversal
SMT forming the reversal. This is a
continuation SMT as it's within the
continuation. So here you can see once
again, we have a candle two closure, a
change in the state of delivery on the
lower time frame, a valid model before
we are looking for SMT. Then we go ahead
and take a look. We don't have SMT
between candle one and candle two, but
we can still keep watching the
correlated market. Here when we go to
form this continuation, what do we do?
We don't take out the high, but on a
correlated market, we do take out the
high. So that is an SMT between candle
two and candle three or a continuation.
That can give us a confluence to trade
this continuation lower and trust that
this candle two can hold. Now we can
also get a double SMT or an SMT between
candle one and two and between two and
three. So we have this reversal SMT, but
we also have this continuation SMT. Now
once again, it's important that you
don't just randomly look for SMTs. You
need to have an actual model that is the
foundation and then you look for an SMT
as a confluence. So let's get into
TradingView and go over a few examples.
So here we are in our first example and
you can see we have a candle two closure
with a change in the state of delivery
and then we have a reversal SMT or an
SMT with YM. This is on NQ from candle
two to candle one. That gives us an
extra confirmation that this can reverse
here and we can get an expansion lower
in candle three. Now why am I not
looking at this candle two in a bullish
scenario? Well because if we follow the
low, find the high, we have not closed
through the series of down close
candles. So it is only valid to look
short in this scenario.
So, let's see what happens here.
You can see we do get that sell-off to
our targets, and then we get a
continuation in candle four.
Let's continue ahead and see if we can
find another example.
So, here we have a candle two closure,
bullish, but let's see if it works out.
There is no SMT between candle one and
candle two. Does SMT form between candle
two and candle three?
Well, as we let this play ahead,
it does not. It invalidates the T-spot
and then takes out the low. Now, here we
have an SMT, and you can see ES and YM
have not taken out this low, while NQ
has. But, like I said, I don't want to
randomly use SMT without context, so I'm
going to wait for the candle closure.
And here you can see we make a new low,
and then it will update the SMT. It is
in replay, so it will be a bit delayed,
but we have a change in the state of
delivery with SMT once again. Let's wait
for the closure.
So, here we have a closure now, right?
So, a candle two closure with a change
in the state of delivery, and now this
SMT with YM, or this reversal, is valid
to look for long setups.
Let's see what happens.
We do trade higher into our previous
target, right? This range high, and we
trade higher. On reversal SMTs, we want
to first wait for a model or a
framework. You can trade candle two, but
I prefer to look for a continuation in
candle three. So, that would be a candle
two closure with a change in the state
of delivery, and then I'll look for a
SMT. So, that is a divergence between
the assets, so you can see here we are
in on NQ, in which case NQ took out this
previous low, but if we go to YM here,
you'll notice YM does not take out this
previous low, and you can see how it
shows that SMT there. So, taking a look
at YM, what is YM here? This is actually
a case where YM is a continuation SMT or
an SMT between candle three and candle
two. It is a bit messy and that's why I
would prefer to take a look at this on
NQ and focus on the reversal SMT.
As this candle three gives a much
cleaner expansion. Let's get into
another example. Now, one quick example
here. I did say that I do prefer to
trade the continuation in candle three
and candle four, but I know many of you
like to trade the reversal in candle
two. So, how do we use SMT with that?
Well, first you're going to need a
candle that actually supports expansion
and that's what I mean by finding a
setup that is valid before you look for
SMT. Here you can see if we are
reversing off of our previous day's
high, we do have a small wick which
supports expansion. We have a change in
the state of delivery and then you can
see that reversal SMT. So, gold has this
SMT with gold euro, gold pound here and
that supports expansion lower. So, if
you want to use SMT on candle two or
with in the reversal candle before the
closure, it has to support expansion
lower. Let's see how this works out.
We get that expansion to the EQ. It
fails the EQ and then takes out that
previous lows or those targets down
there.
So, hopefully that makes sense. If you
are going to trade the reversal, you
need to have the proper framework for
it. So, here we are in another example
and this is what I want to show you with
it needs to have a proper framework
first before you look for SMT. If we're
taking a look at this asset here, gold,
you can see we do have a candle two
closure. Do we have an hourly change in
the state of delivery? I find the high.
I find the series of candles that made
that high. We have yet to close below
this level. So, we don't have a change
in the state of delivery yet. So, when
looking at correlated assets, yes, I
have an SMT here as the correlated asset
has made a lower high while gold has
made a higher high, but I do not care
about that SMT because I'm not finding
SMT and then applying a framework to it.
I'm finding a framework and then
applying SMT to that. So, what would I
need to wait for? I would need to wait
for an hourly change in the state of
delivery.
Here you can see, we do get that change
in the state of delivery. Then it marks
out the SMT, right? So, you notice we
have to have the proper framework before
we can look for an SMT. There we do get
expansion into the low, a retracement,
and then a continuation into that
further low. There are more advanced
things to do if you do want to trade
like this, but it just becomes a lot
more difficult than it needs to be. So,
I like to keep it simple. If my model
has not formed, I do not look for SMT
yet.
Here we are on NQ. We have a candle two
closure on the daily. We have an SMT and
a change in the state of delivery. So,
we have a valid model to be looking
lower here. Let's see what happens.
We open low first
and then we trade higher and invalidate
the setup. So, what does this mean? Just
because you see a valid setup and an SMT
doesn't mean that it's going to work.
You still need that intraday
confirmation that price is going to
either open, form a new protected swing,
and trade lower, or open, make a new
protected swing, and then trade lower.
If we look at how we formed intraday
here or the daily profile, we open low
first and then expanded higher,
invalidating that EQ, thus invalidating
the possibility for me to look for a
bearish expansion. So, just because you
see SMT doesn't mean everything's going
to work. Nothing works 100% of the time.
So, here we are in our next example. We
are on USDCAD. So, I would be looking
for the dollar for SMT. Here you can
see, we have a candle two closure. We
have an hourly change in the state of
delivery. There is no reversal SMT or
SMT between candle one and two. So, the
only way that we would look for an SMT
is between the correlated asset, right?
On the continuation. Let's see what
happens.
Here you can see.
Now dollar has taken out this previous
high. So, there is an SMT between this
current day's high and the previous day
high with dollar. So, this is a
continuation SMT showing that if we have
the intraday confirmation, there's more
confluence to see this to trade lower.
Here you can see we reverse and then we
get a continuation lower into the
targets below.
So, the difference between a reversal
SMT and a continuation SMT is a reversal
SMT would form at the reversal or candle
one and candle two. A continuation SMT
is an SMT between candle two and candle
three or on the lower time frames this
high and this high here, which is marked
out via my indicator. So, let's take a
look at another example.
So, here's another example of a
continuation SMT. So, you can see we
have a candle two closure. It is still a
bullish closure. So, we want to wait for
more confirmation intraday just because
I don't have as much confidence in this
setup. So, let's let this play forward.
And you can see
ES and NQ are already taking out this
previous high. So, does that tell us we
want to trade this lower? No, not yet.
We still need that intraday confirmation
or for a reversal to form.
And here you can see
we get a sweep of this little
consolidation, a nice candle two
closure, and that is an intraday
reversal, and we're using this
continuation SMT as a confluence for
this move. We're seeing that YM hasn't
taken out its previous day high while ES
and NQ have. Let's see how this works
out. We get a continuation lower. So,
you can see and just review, a
continuation SMT is showing that the
other assets, so if we go to ES or NQ,
you can see that they are above their
previous day's high, while YM is not
above that previous day high, and there
is a divergence at an important level.
Here we are in our final example, and
this is an example of a double SMT. Now,
what is that? That is when we have a
reversal between candle two and candle
one, or that reversal SMT, and a
three, or that continuation SMT. And you
can see this price action here is quite
messy, and so having these double SMTs,
in terms of participating in this price,
or even looking for a setup. So, let's
see what happens. Once again, this alone
does not mean that I'm looking for a
setup. I want to see that intraday
confirmation, or the wick high of the
daily form, before I can trade away from
it. And here you can see, intraday we
form a new continuation SMT right there.
So, I could look for price to trade
lower from here,
or I could go down to a lower time frame
and look for a further continuation. But
there is where we would get to our Let's
see if we can get that.
We do. And you can see we got a further
continuation as we traded back up into
this fair value gap, and then formed
another continuation out of that. So,
even if we miss the intraday reversal,
we could have got a continuation towards
London, or even into early New York
before we expand lower.
Now, I hope this video was helpful, and
you understand what a reversal versus a
continuation SMT looks like within my
fractal model, and what a double SMT
looks like. Once again, I want you to
remember, you don't just look for an SMT
and then randomly apply it to a model.
You first want to have an actual
framework and a model you are looking
for, then look to apply that SMT. With
that said, I hope you enjoyed, and I'll
see you guys next week. Have a good one.
>> [music]
>> If you are looking for a way to work
more closely with me and get more
one-on-one support within your trading,
you can click the link below. We have a
waitlist for our program, so you can
join and I will let you know when we
have new openings.